Congrats, guys.
(Amy)
Uh, well, wait.
Thank you.
Um, okay, you can sit.
So, as you all
know, I'm Amy.
And as I'm
sure you also know,
I'd like to do something
a little more special
than what we've been seeing so
far tonight.
When I first met Becca,
I was all, "What the hecka?"
We'd go to a club together
in all kinds of weather.
She slept with so many guys,
I couldn't believe my eyes.
'Cause it was
so many.
She once went black.
And we thought she'd
never come back.
But then she met Dan.
He was a white man.
The only problem was
that Dan and I once dated,
a fact Becca always hated!
But then they
went to therapy.
And now they are
so happ-y.
So let's raise
a glass to the--
This wedding is slammin'!
Okay, you guys,
let's dance.
She never sticks
the landing.
Is this Veuve--
What is it?
Dom-- Slammin'.
♪
And may God
bless Rebecca's family,
who are still trying to find
the monster
who killed their beautiful
daughter.
Everyone wanted me to say
a couple words, just--
Uh, I guess, uh, one of
Rebecca's friends
would like to
say a few words.
Hey, guys, I'm Amy.
So I wrote something
that I think
expresses
how we all feel.
Here goes.
Does this come out?
Yes.
You don't care?
Quite all right.
Rebecca has gone
to a better place,
and I already
miss her face.
I'm sure whoever killed
her has gone far away.
It would be best to stop
looking and start a new day.
The saddest part is
that Dan is now alone,
but he should know that he can
always call me on the phone.
So let's raise a glass
to a beautiful lass.
Dan can also message
me on Facebook
and I put my number
up on my Instagram.
Is this Veuve?
Dom?
Oh-- Is that okay?
("Law & Order" sting)
You're not answering
my questions!
Where were you on the
night Rebecca was killed?
So let's raise
a glass...
(gavel banging)
If you do that one more time,
I'm gonna lose my (bleep).
I didn't mean it.
I sincerely apologize.
And I swear I'm not
guilty, you guys.
I'm freaking out.
(gavel banging)
Any last words?
Rebecca's husband was
never in love with her.
I hope I get a call
from the governor.
So let's raise a glaaaaa...
(electric buzzing)
... sssssssss....
I'm sorry, I just
couldn't take it anymore.